[Музика]
Привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть Наталія Лашкар, давайте
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжимо розмову про
шкільне життя та освіту, тож якщо ви
думаєте про наші уроки, ми вже
обговорювали різні класи, різні
предмети, які ми створили  проект нашої
школи та школи нашої мрії,
тому ми також говорили про вчителів
цієї школи, тож давайте уявимо, що у
нас готова школа, у нас є свої
класи, які ми
хочемо мати у своїй школі все, що ви хочете мати
предмети, які ми хочемо вивчати,
ви писали мені про це і ви
вибрали вчителів і якості
рис характерів, які
повинен мати вчитель, тепер настав час навчальної програми,
але перш ніж ми виберемо програму і
поговоримо про освіту в Україні та
інші  країни Я хочу, щоб ви
зосередилися на мотиваційних речах, тому
що вас мотивує чому ви ходите до
школи щодня я знаю, що ви повинні,
але є речі, t  те, що
вчителі можуть вам розповісти, показати чи попросити
вас зробити, що у вас є бажання і
бажання ходити до школи, тому це називається
мотивацією, і сьогодні ми також поговоримо
про правила, тому давайте почнемо з
інтерв’ю, у мене було фантастичне  поговори з моєю
подругою, яка є директором
приватної школи в Греції, тож давайте зустрінемося з
нею та поговоримо з нею, привіт, як ти сьогодні,
добре, бо ти бачиш, що я
сиджу надворі, тому що
тут, у Греції, чудовий сонячний спекотний день,
я бачу  Тож, не могли б
ви представитися нашим студентам, звичайно, доброго
ранку всім мене звати Васудева
Пулу, і у мене був викладач-тренер із
Express publishing, а також директор
з навчання великої школи пілотів,
яку Express publishing має в Греції,
дуже дякую.  ви справжній
експерт, і ми маємо честь мати вас на
нашому уроці,
тому Васа скажіть мені, будь ласка, чи це велика
школа, адже це приватна мовна
школа, у нас близько 2000
учнів відвідують наші заняття
англійською мовою F  rench Італійська Іспанська Німецька
і тепер ми викладаємо грецьку мову для
іноземців О фантастично я сподіваюся, що одного
дня я буду твоїм учнем з грецької мови,
тому що я зараз вивчаю грецьку мову, зараз чудово
чекаю на тебе, дякую,
добре, ба, то не могли б ви сказати нам, що я
знаю, що  більшість приватних мовних шкіл
мають лише класні кімнати у своїх
школах, але я знаю, що у вас є
дві додаткові кімнати, це дуже важливо, чи
можете ви розповісти нам про те, що,
звісно,
важаємо нашу школу чимось бі
ьше, ніж проста школа, тому у на
є  велика комп’ютерна лабораторія насправді зараз у нас є
дві великі комп’ютерні лабораторії, і ми прямуємо
до третьої, куди студенти приходять і
виконують свою електронну частину домашнього завдання,
тож якщо ви знайомі з нашими книгами,
ви знаєте про електронну книгу та знаєте
про цифрову  платформу, тож де б
вам не було призначено домашнє завдання з
цих двох компонентів наших підручників,
вони приходять до комп’ютерної лабораторії й сидять
там, де присутні вчителі, яким
допомагають вчителі та  роблять
домашнє завдання в комп’ютерній лабораторії, і
є друга кімната, яка дуже
особлива для нас, це наш театр,
це актова зала, але зі сценою,
але з мікрофонами сцени, ви називаєте це, у
нас є все, тому що ми
робимо це ми  влаштовуємо
власні театральні вистави, щоб
студенти фактично ставали акторами та
актрисами, і вони виступали англійською мовою,
починаючи з дуже юного віку, від
п’яти-шестирічних
до тих пір, поки їм
, скажімо, 70 років, і вони беруть участь  у наших
виставах я добре бачу, що це чудово,
тому драма важлива для студентів,
і це є обов'язковим для всіх
цих студентів, або вони просто грають,
скажімо, бажаючи, щоб вони
так чи інакше не повинні були брати участь, це можуть
бути актори та актриси  на сцені це
можуть бути співаки в хорі, і,
звичайно, вони також можуть виступати, щоб у нашій школі
навчали та практикували презентаційні навички,
і ніби це було
реальне життя, вони виходять на сцену і  Вони
пропонують цікаві теми
батькам і вчителям, які відвідують, щоб
вони були готові до того, що буде далі,
тому що ми всі знаємо, що коли ми працюємо, нас
попросять дати інтерв’ю, щоб
представити речі, якщо ми працюємо особливо в
бізнесі, ми будемо представляти всі
час, тому ми готуємо наших студентів
до цього, допомагаючи їм з раннього
віку. Я бачу, що це чудово
, схоже, ви готуєте своїх
учнів до майбутнього життя, тому практикуєте
їхні життєві навички, це чудово,
тому не могли б ви розповісти нам, як ви
мотивуєте свої  учням брати
активну участь і виконувати домашнє завдання, тому що
ми іноді боремося з цим, у нас є
бали від одного до дванадцяти дванадцять є
найкращим, що щодо вас у вашій шкільній
домашній роботі чарівний світ, вчителі люблять
це, учні ненавидять це, тому ми повинні знайти
спосіб поєднати  ці двоє, наша любов та
їхня ненависть, і зробили це успішною
історією, і це сталося через наші
платформи digibook, тому ми
організували наші  розділіть на три великі
команди, щоб у нас були тигри, леви
та гепарди, є лідери, у нас
є лідери, я лідер
команди тигрів, а потім учні
діляться на ці три
щоразу, коли вони виконують завдання на своїй
платформі digibook на  місія, яку
призначає перевірка вчителя для
тестованого простору, добре, тому щоразу, коли вони роблять
це, вони отримують зірки та бали та
Алекса, і вони збирають бали для своєї
команди в кінці навчального року, ми
бачимо, як кожна команда впоралася, а потім нагороджуємо
їм великий трофей, а потім у нас є великий
банер з назвою та символом
команди, і це прикрашає нашу школу на
цілий рік, тому що ця команда була командою-
переможцем, яку виграли Тигри минулого року, тому ми
були переможцями минулого року, ми
втратити багато часу в цьому році я не знаю,
що відбувається, все добре, інакше
ми подивимося, як це, якщо ви скажете, що ми маємо
деякий час, звичайно, так що студенти
не ця система, це участь у
командах правильно так, тому що, по суті, це
це конкурентоспроможність, але в позитивному сенсі
і для нас це добре, тому що домашнє завдання
виконано для учнів, це приємно, тому
що це не схоже на домашнє завдання, це як
грати в цифрову гру, тому це добре, а
також, отримуючи ці очки, вони мають
свій власний аватар, щоб вони  вибирати
одяг та аксесуари та одягати їх
аватар, щоб ви знали, що цифрова платформа
запропонувала нам інструмент для підходу до нового
покоління, нові діти сьогодні настільки
відрізняються від тих, якими ми були в
дитинстві, тому ми повинні знайти спосіб підійти до
вас  це спосіб, яким
вони мають платформу, щоб використати
ідею, що я роблю це для себе
та своєї команди, вони навіть позичають книги
з бібліотеки, яку ви знаєте, через
digibook, ми завантажили книги, і
вони знають, що вони можуть  перейдіть на їх
дигікнижку, виберіть, прийдіть до школи,
заберіть її, прочитайте, і це дасть їм
більше балів. Я бачу, що це чудово, схоже,
що це дійсно мотивує учнів,
і наші студенти хотіли
б відповідати  передбачте також у цій системі,
скажіть мені, будь ласка, відмовтеся
від кубка, який отримують студенти, і всієї
цієї реклами, що банер там
через святість на наступний
навчальний рік, чи ви організуєте
щось інше, як вечірку для них,
можливо, якісь лікування  Я не знаю
нічого, що могло б їх мотивувати, як-от
додаткові очки, додаткові бонуси, ми намагаємося постійно
тримати їх в курсі нових
речей, тому так, ми проводимо змагання
протягом року, у нас також є власна
Стіна слави, як ми називаємо її, де є найкращі
учні кожного рівня друкують свої імена,
і це залишається там на кожен наступний
рік, тому вони все
одно відчувають, що добре, я повинен прагнути, я
можу бути найкращим, а також переможцями
книга зігріває дітей, які
прочитали найбільше книг  від бібліотеки вони отримують
нагороди, ми маємо велику роль
наприкінці року, і ми даємо їм свої нагороди,
вони дрони або ви знаєте планшети і
таке інше, тому їм це дуже подобається,
але крім усього  Ми також намагаємося
донести до учнів, що
наша школа – це більше, ніж школа, тому ми
повинні пропагувати цінності, тому ми організовуємо
інші заходи, які залучають учнів
до реалій цього світу.
викликали організації, які
опікуються бездомними тваринами, їх
познайомили з ідеями, як допомогти
тваринам зміцнити, чому ми не повинні взяти
тварину, якщо ми не впевнені в цьому,
ми йдемо в театр,
до нас приходять відомі люди, про які говорять з нами
їхню роботу та про вас знають
подібні речі, які змусять дітей
відчути, що це більше, ніж школа,
тому що дурні – це більше, ніж школи, ми
вчимо цінності, ми створюємо
громадян майбутнього, і тому нам потрібно навчити їх
набагато більше, ніж просто англійська  Я згоден, я
повністю згоден з
вами, тому дуже дякую за вашу розмову.
Я сподіваюся, що ми застосуємо деякі
з ваших ідей у наших школах, і я вп
внений, що учням сподобаються ваші ід
ї, і вони хочуть використати їх  вони в
школі їхньої мрії, тому наступного разу
я поділюся з вами ідеями, які
вони використають, це було б чудово,
і було чудово поговорити з тобою, сумую за тобою,
ми давно не бачилися з тобою
ці дивні умови, які ми
відчуваємо, діти продовжують гарну
роботу. Я знаю, що онлайн-уроки та
онлайн-реальність – це не те саме, що
фізична присутність у класі, але повірте
мені, що ці люди
чудово працюють, так тримати, дуже дякую
як ви бачите, у нас була фантастична розмова
з Wausau, і давайте підсумуємо
ідеї щодо системи мотивації
та шкільних правил, які вона має в середній
школі, і ми можемо застосувати ці ідеї в
наших школах, тож, перш за все, говоримо
про класні кімнати, які вона згадала
що у них є дві важливі кімнати, які
вони, ви пам'ятаєте так,
комп'ютерний кабінет і цей театр або
актовий зал, тому у них є велика сцена,
і вони щороку мають виступи,
і студенти не можуть пропускати ці
заняття  усі беруть участь у цьому
виступі, розповідаючи про систему мотивації,
вони використовують цифрову платформу для
виконання домашнього завдання, тому у них немає
паперового домашнього завдання, вони не мають
жодних робочих зошитів і не виконують вправи,
використовуючи сковороду, вони виконують домашнє завдання
за допомогою цифрової платформи  і вони заповнюють
це онлайн, що означає, що це
як гра для студентів, це також
цікаво, тому що вони отримують очки, і
це приємно, що ви отримуєте більше балів, і ви
можете грати зі своїм аватаром, це дуже
конкурентно,
я б хотів вчитися так  тож ви
можете використати ці ідеї для свого шкільного
проекту «Школа вашої мрії»,
додавши ці мотиваційні точки та
велику частину створення власного мотиватора,
немає системи, тепер давайте зосередимося на шкільних
правилах, давайте почнемо подивимося на
перше, про яке вчитель каже, будь тихо, добре
то яке правило для учня в
моїй школі. Я повинен мовчати, це
перше правило, і ви можете побачити
інфографіку, тож давайте намалюємо ці картинки
, щоб  запам'ятайте ці правила, вони нам
знадобляться пізніше, тому я буду використовувати їх
у своїй школі, я повинен бути тихим, давайте
з наступним, будьте ввічливі, вчитель
каже так, щоб правило було в моїй
школі, я повинен бути ввічливим,
тому я  підніміть мою руку я ввічливий ще
раз яке правило в моїй школі я
маю бути ввічливим давайте продовжимо
говорити англійською каже вчитель тож
правило таке я повинен говорити англійською давайте намалюй
це
так я повинен говорити англійською давайте підемо
до наступного вчителя  каже не користуйтеся своїм
мобільним телефоном, і правило таке, що в моїй
школі я не можу користуватися своїм телефоном, тому давайте
намалюємо його, щоб у моїй школі я не міг користуватися
мобільним телефоном, ми тримаємо їх у шафці,
тому не слухайте  музика
яка роль подивіться я не повинен
слухати музику що каже вчитель
не слухай музику правильно, тому ми
не можемо слухати музику в школі,
давайте намалюємо її, щоб деякі з вас могли сказати,
що ми можемо  не слухай музику в
школі, чому так правило таке, що ти
не повинен слухати музику під час
уроку під час  перерви все добре, ви
можете одягнути навушники і послухати
музику, тому під час уроку ні, ви не можете
слухати музику, давайте
продовжимо подивимося, вчитель каже: мм-хм, їжте
жуйки, тому не їжте жуйки,
а учень може сказати  Я не можу їсти
жуйки в моїй школі, тому що, по-перше,
вони небезпечні, по-друге, я можу
пошкодити шкільне майно,
тому
я не буду використовувати жуйку, тому без бульбашок, без
жуйки, добре в моїй школі, я не можу
їсти жуйку  гумка давайте продовжимо
наступний
не пробуйте це на столі, каже
вчитель, і правило таке: я не повинен писати
на своєму столі, тож давайте намалюємо це, щоб
на столі були стіл і сковорідка, і я кажу,
що я не повинен  не малюй на столі
ще раз у моїй школі я не повинен малювати на
своєму столі давайте продовжимо у нас є ще
два вчитель каже не спізнюйся, тому я
не повинен спізнюватися в школу, тому я малюю
годинник це  означає, що я повинен прийти вчасно
і я не повинен спізнюватися я не повинен спізнюватися
давайте продовжувати не бігти по коридору
це моє  улюблене правило учні сміються
Ронні, але вчителі їм це не подобається,
щоб учень міг сказати, що я не повинен бігати
в коридорі, давайте намалюємо його,
щоб не бігати, не бігати, не бігати в коридорі
або в моїй школі, я не повинен бігати в
коридори тепер давайте підсумуємо всі ці
правила, використовуючи модальні дієслова have a look
ми використовуємо mass or must't have to і стріляти
після must have to and shoot ми просто
використовуємо дієслово без частки - ви повинні
говорити англійською, ви повинні бути ввічливі
потрібно бути ввічливим
або ви повинні говорити англійською, і ви
, звичайно, повинні бути вчасно,
ви повинні бути ввічливі,
ви повинні мовчати, якщо один
дійсно дуже сильний, тому ви не повинні використовувати
свій телефон, це означає, що немає
футлярів  що ви використовуєте свій телефон у
класі, це дуже сильне правило, ви
не повинні або ви не повинні їсти жуйку,
тому що це небезпечно, або ви не повинні
знову бігати в коридорі, тому що
це небезпечно, потрібно бути трохи легше
він не такий сильний, як, наприклад
, маєш бути  ввічливий є деякі
випадки, коли ти можеш бути собою, і
ти висловлюєшся, тому ми не можемо сказати, що ти
повинен бути ввічливим, ми говоримо, що ти повинен
спробувати з іншим, ти маєш
розмовляти англійською, це також було б добре,
давайте почнемо знімати  стріляти ще
легше, це як порада, хороша
порада, тому ви повинні мовчати, тому
коли ви говорите, що маєте бути ввічливим
, це означає, що це звучить легше для вашого розуму,
це не так сильно, як потрібно, і
ви також повинні говорити англійською це
це хороша порада, і всі ці правила
, які позначені червоним кольором, я б дотримувався їх як
обов'язково, тому ви не повинні користуватися телефоном,
не слухайте музику під час уроку
, не використовуйте жувальні гумки,
тому що це небезпечно для
вас  не можна писати на таблицях це
маршрут, ви також повинні бути вчасно не
спізнюйтеся і, будь ласка, не бігайте по
коридору, ви не повинні бігати в коридорі,
звичайно, ці правила звучать дуже дуже
суворо, і школа, ймовірно, є
буде нудно для студентів, яких вони ненавидять
у цій школі ми можемо використовувати різні слова
, щоб зробити її легшою, тому ці
слова повинні мати, і вони завжди
звучать дуже сильно для нас, і здається,
що це нудна школа, там так
багато правил, і учні зазвичай ненавидять
такі школи, такі різні слова  може допомогти
нам перефразувати правила, і це
буде звучати простіше для нас,
давайте подивимося, ми можемо використовувати такі слова, як обмеження
уникати або триматися подалі від давайте спробуємо,
наприклад, обмежити використання телефону, що означає,
що на деяких уроках я, як вчитель, можу
дозволити  Ви можете використовувати свій телефон, наприклад,
ми можемо мати анонімний диктант або ми
можемо використовувати різні програми, які ми
вже пробували з вами, програма історія вмирає,
тому я попросив вас використовувати свій
телефон, давайте не
їсти жуйки, щоб було легше  для
вас, ніж слухати фразу не
їж жуйки уникай їсти
жуйки, ви бачите різницю і
тримайтеся подалі від бігати,
наприклад, по коридорах і
давайте подивимося, як  ми складаємо речення, використовуючи
ці слова,
тож після limit і уникати ми використовуємо дієслово
з формою ing, наприклад limit talking
to route people або уникати їсти жувальних
гумок уникати говорити занадто голосно та уникати
ми зазвичай використовуємо триматися подалі від
чого-небудь триматися подалі від чого-небудь або
Хтось також тримайтеся подалі від грубих
людей, а тепер дозвольте мені показати вам кілька
прикладів наших учнів із різних шкіл,
тож давайте
подивимося на ці два плакати, давайте почнемо
з першого, тому перше правило полягає в тому, що
ви повинні тримати мобільний телефон у місці,
тому не  не користуйтеся мобільним телефоном під
час уроку, якщо ваш учитель не дозволяє
вам, тому шафка — це шафи, ви
кладете туди свої телефони, і вони залишаються
там на уроках на перервах, ви
можете користуватися ними, це добре,
тож давайте продовжимо, ви можете»  т носити густий
макіяж, і це означає, що макіяж нормальний,
але він повинен бути дуже легким, а важкий
макіяж не підходить для школи, це
нормально для вечірки після школи, але це
круто зараз, не робіть цього та останнього
ви не можете обманювати на тестах, це дуже
гарне правило, і вони люблять його, тому що
шахрайство не добре правильно, краще
вивчити це заздалегідь, і добре вивчити,
і пройти тест, і бути чесним
весь час, щоб не обманювати хлопці, давайте дивитися
тут це більш традиційно, тут ви
бачите лише речення та дуже мало
зображень, таких як інфографіка, тому давайте
почнемо, ви повинні прийти раніше або
не спізнюватися, пам’ятайте правильно, давайте продовжимо,
ви знову повинні бути вчасно на уроки,
це дуже важливо  правило, тому
що вчитель може почати урок
з невеликого диктанту або короткої
розмови, яка буде
важливою, і ви не можете її пропустити. Третє правило,
ви повинні носити спеціальний одяг
для фізкультури, бути готовим до занять
фізкультурою, тому що коли ви займаєтеся в  тренажерний зал, у якому не можна
носити джинси чи шкільну форму, це не
підходить для шкільних уроків, таких як фізкультура,
тому номер чотири, ви можете наносити макіяж, тому
це означає, як ця жінка, мабуть,
тому що тут у нас є правила щодо
макіяжу я можу  Я розумію, що це
жінки, і ця жінка каже, що немає макіяжу,
і тут у нас є фраза або ряд,
можна нанести свій макіяж, але правило полягає в тому, що
ви не можете мати важкий макіяж, легкий макіяж
- це добре, красиве обличчя і останній, який у
вас є  носити документи, що посвідчують особу,
важливо, тому, будь ласка, візьміть його до школи,
які правила ми можемо використовувати в
школі, щоб ми не говорили про шкільну
форму, чи важливо для вас
, чи хочете ви мати шкільну форму в
школі, і це може бути  Джинси, мабуть,
або біла футболка і
кросівки, або ви хотіли б мати взуття та більш офіційний
стиль, як жакет і брюки для
жінок, це може бути сукня чи спідниця або
знову штани, тож подумайте про
шкільну форму, чи б ви хотіли  додайте
ці речі до своєї школи, тому, хлопці, настав
час для нашого домашнього завдання. Я сказав вам, що ми
вже говорили про школу нашої
мрії, і ми все ще завершуємо цей
проект, тому я хотів би, щоб ви оновили
свій проект інформацією, яку ми
маємо на диску  розглянути сьогодні, перш за все,
мотиваційну систему, як би ви
мотивували учнів вашої школи до
активної участі чи б ви хотіли
додати події різні класи,
ймовірно, цифрові домашні завдання або, ймовірно,
бали ви можете мати власну назву для
цих балів ви створюєте власну
валюту добре  потім перейдіть до
набору шкільних правил, які ви хотіли б
мати у своїй школі, ви можете використовувати
правила, які ми обговорювали сьогодні, або
додайте свої власні школи та додайте свої власні
правила, не забувайте також про
правила для вчителів  тому ми просимо вас
робити багато речей, і нам потрібно
говорити про себе, тому, наприклад,
вчитель повинен бути креативним, вчитель
повинен приносити цікаві завдання на
уроки, як ці речі, або вчитель
повинен показувати нам різні відео, тому подумайте
про правила  для вчителів також,
і останній пункт - це шкільна форма, чи
б ви хотіли, щоб вона тепер була в шкільній
формі, і ви дозволяєте своїм учням
носити все, що вони хочуть, тому дякую вам
дуже радий уроку, і ми
побачимося наступного разу, до побачення,
[музика].